hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
kontakt hier am etwas späteren abend
hier auf meinem kanal ich habe ja in der
letzten folge mal gefragt was wollt ihr
diesen kontakt haben wollt ihr dass ich
mir eure kommentare beantworten wir so
ein paar daraus suchen wir darauf
eingehe oder wollt ihr dass ich euch 20
dinge sage die ich über alles liebe die
ich mir einfach mal raus suche und es
kam ganz klar bei raus dass sich die
über 20 dinge da machen soll deswegen
mache ich das ja damals bevor das video
los geht möchte ich noch in chur zwei
sachen sagen und zwar werde ich immer
wieder gefragt hey kontrastiert das
immer etwas von instagram aber man
findet er keinen kontrakt auf instagram
jahr ich heiße auf instagram laser lukas
auch in der beschreibung da könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken und dann nicht
einfach wieder weiter dumme umfragen ich
hab dann anderen nehme ich habe zwei
identitäten müsste westen und die zweite
sache die ich noch eben kurz ansprechen
wollte war ich habe jetzt eine umfrage
gemacht was ihr im nächsten kontakt
haben möchtet also ihr könnt ihr alles
mit bestimmen das was da gewinnen werde
ich den nächsten kontakt machen die
findet ihr oben erste linken der
beschreibung einfach draufklicken da
könnte da kann jeder einfach abstimmen
ohne kaum zu machen das ist super
organisiert und blablabla macht das
einfach da wäre ich auf jeden fall der
der dankbare beiträgt wieder keiner luft
waren vielleicht kann die man reden wenn
man dann darüber also 20 dinge die ich
mag das war erstmal immens schwer das
alles zu finden weil jetzt ist genau so
wie bei den wie bei dem video 20 dinge
die ich hasse und 20 fakten über mich
habe ich auch schon gemacht das war
genauso blöd da und zwar muss man sich
diese sachen man weiß zwar was man was
man so marx und dass man nicht mag aber
man weiß dass nur immer in den
situationen
man weiß nur in bestimmten situationen
wo das macht aber spaß dann hat man
wieder vergessen und ich könnte jetzt
theoretisch eine ganze woche lang immer
die sachen aufschreibe die mir spaß
machen oder die ich halt mag oder so
dann werde ich locker bei 100 und jetzt
hatte ich schon probleme einfach so auf
anhieb 20 sachen raus zu schreiben
daraufhin familia kassel was jetzt
machen könnten wäre weil das sind
bestimmte sachen bei die ihr auch geld
findet dann schreibt einfach mal immer
neuen kommentar 1 und dann immer weniger
tage schreibt ihr dann habe ich auch
oder habe ich so unsere blabla dann
macht ihr neu kommentar 2 und dann kann
ich das genau sehen wie viele sachen von
euch das auf euch auch zu treffen und
dann würde ich sagen fangen jetzt an und
ich wünsche dir zwei minuten reden ohne
dass irgendwas produktives warum
gekommen das beste also die erste sache
die mega mega geil finde es einfach in
mcdrive
ja einfach der mc drive bei mcdonald's
ich liebe das man fährt da rein mit dem
auto chili hat musikern und dann redet
man einfach mit diesen leuten das mega
witzig damit den leuten einfach zu dritt
zu reden was zu bestellen
eben weil sie nicht bin im dance komisch
was sowas angeht aber ich finde das
irgendwie möglich und das witzig die
zweite sache ist ich liebe ich kann es
jetzt immer sagen die blöde sache ist
ich liebe geblieben das ist ein bisschen
doof finden die richtig cool wenn man
geduscht hat und dann irgendwie nach dem
sport buschmann und danach fährt man
durchs kalte nach hause gegen die weiß
nicht man fühlt sich irgendwie so mega
frisch hat die kapuze auf man fühlt sich
frisch und man hat kapuze auf und man
fühlt sich frisch
man hat kapuze drittens ich mag
schwimmen ich finde das irgendwie
richtig geil wenn man einfach so dieses
wasser schwimmt und allgemein wasser
wenn man sich mal dass das einfach nur
vor augen führt ich bin sondern eine
person die verletzlichen alles mögliche
reihen also ich kann über alles
nachdenken und philosophieren
aber bei wassers ist echt zu wasser ist
ein stoff ist ein material wo man durch
schwimmen kann wo man wo lässt sich also
ich kann meine gedanken schlecht so auf
den punkt bringen aber man muss einfach
mal länger darüber nachdenken dass man
da so durchspielen dann ist man halt
direkt nass und was das für
eigenschaften hat und nicht mehr auf
chemischer ebene afrikanischer ebene
aber weil sie nicht beim wasser läuft
halt viertens ich liebe gute musik also
ist nicht natürlich es gibt keine gute
und schlechte musik es gibt nur
verschiedene geschmäcker jede musik ist
irgendwie eine spezielle form von musik
und ist in einer speziellen form gut
oder halt nicht so gut aber das sind
halt persönliche meinungen nur was ich
mag halt ich mag halt so electro house
dance hip hop black ich mag ihn wie fast
alles also ich mag richtig geile musik
und dann irgendwie im club dazu abgeben
und dann blabla dass auf jeden fall
hammergeil wollt ihr das ist übrigens
auch der umfrage mit drin
wollt ihr dass ich im nächsten kontakt
eventuell mal meine lieblingsmusik
vorstelle dann klicke jetzt auf den
obersten league in der beschreibung ich
bekomme dafür nichts dass ich das sage
ich das einfach nur ein guter weg um nun
fragt zu machen höhnen finde ich auch
mega geil und zwar weil stand haben als
als kind hat mich mein vater irgendwie
gefüllt als wir nehmen die zwei oder
drei watt also dann habe ich eigentlich
gerade geduscht und ich habe immer so
gesagt so
wenn einer den föhn ausgemacht immer
noch weiter gefüllt werden und ja weil
sie nicht sechs ist auch wieder so
komisch und 2 marx einfach wenn ich
drinnen bin und ist draußen stürmt also
wer nicht weiß okay ich bin hier drin
ich bin sicher es ist geil hier drin ist
es schön warm und ich gucke noch draußen
ist einfach das wetter draußen was hat
mich zum beispiel auch richtig oft dabei
zum unterricht weil wo halt heftige
stürme hier mal waren das war richtig
eine woche lang jeden tag in die spuren
also es war grundschule das dritte
klasse oder so schon 10 9 jahre und das
war einfach geil ich kann einfach ich
kann einfach drin sitzt und einfach dem
wetter zu gucken ich weiß ich ich finde
das irgendwie das ganz gut das ist
motorsport das portal 70 liebe drop
moment wenn man irgendwie im club ist
oder wenn man einfach so musik hört also
das bezieht jetzt auch wieder auf die
noch die vierte sache die ich mag mit
der guten musik aber wenn man einfach so
electro hört dann braucht sich der
wieder aus der dritte drittel oder dumm
das ist irgendwie weiß nicht diese
dokumente finde ich richtig geil da
könnte ich wohl einfach achtens auto
fahren einfach autofahren autofahren
macht so spaß autofahren ist richtig
geil einfach die gänge raus hauen oder
oder dann kriegt auch noch für
autobahnen und alles braucht also
autofahren es echt wenn ihr 16 wertet
macht so forderten führerschein das ist
ja das ist schon richtig geil freunden
sich liebe antoine antworten also diesen
teddy teclebrhan der da diese figur
antworten manchmal spielt das ist so
witzig dass es die ich dass das ist das
einzige wo ich mich richtig richtig
schlapp lachen kann von allen videos auf
der kompletten welt da ist dieser oder
von allen comedians oder so das ist
einfach diese dieses selber bis burka
oder was willst du manko nein ich heiße
marco elias gehört die behindert einfach
nur das ist so geil
also ich weiß nicht wie man denen wie
man die nicht feiern kann das ist
einfach erst so wird das jetzt mal was
für alkoholiker unter euch
beziehungsweise leute die feiern gehen
trink mal bacardi razz mit sprite das
werden wahrscheinlich die meisten von
euch kennen aber es ist halt einfach
mega geil hat kriegt davon
der ist süß aber möglich davon noch ein
bisschen mundgeruch
aber wenn ihr dafür eine komplette
bacardi razz dringend auf jeden fall
richtig gut dabei und glaubt mir ich
weiß dass man dann richtig gut dabei bis
11 ich mag's wenn man sachen im internet
bestellt das ist einfach so einfach wenn
man nicht alles so amazon account und
dann drückt man einfach drauf bestellt
ist es in zwei drei tagen hier und dann
geht es auch schon weiter in den zwölf
effekt hier zwölfte sachen die ich mag
und zwar einfach sachen auspacken wenn
man sachen bestellt hat und man packt
die sachen aus oder wenn man die sachen
ebenso gekauft hat oder so oder einfach
irgendwie technik sachen auspacken oder
so man weiß einfach ok wack das jetzt
aus yahoo ist nicht sachen auspacken
find ich richtig gut
ein glücksgefühl bei läuft 13 facebook
weins facebook weiß ist das aller geld-
oder diese sieben sekunden videos ich
finde das so gut ich hab gerade deckel
in der hand von meiner kamera und ein
facebook sind echt richtig geld also
facebook ganz einfach so ganz ganz kurze
videos die trotzdem immens witzig sind
ich poste auch manchmal bei facebook
soll videos aber also facebook videos in
echt sogar witzig immer dass es richtig
geil 14 chinesisches team essen also
irgendwie gebratener reis mit krabben
oder mit schicken oder irgendwie
frühlingsrollen oder irgendwie sowas
oder diese kleinen coup teilchen sind
die krabben chips da das ist alles wahr
chinesisches essen ich könnte mich
reinlichkeit und baden alter war es
sogar 15 ist eine sache die
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch macht aber
ich hab jetzt einfach mal mit dazu
geschrieben und zwar wenn man abends im
bett liegt und man nimmt einfach sein
handy raus und guckt da drauf und sie
dann halt nachrichten nachrichten
nachrichten und dann geht man an den
candy crash und macht ihm den candy
crash level dann geht man wieder in
facebook dann wieder ein instagram oder
ist man quasi wenn ich mir sage okay ich
es ist halb zwölf in der woche ich gehe
jetzt ins bett um viertel vor zwölfte
networking zähne putze was alles und
dann bin ich aber doch bis viertel vor
eins einfach wacht und check einfach
alle seid alle netzwerke dann hat da wie
eine geschriebene star wieder sachen
eine gruppe gesendet worden
kann man hier wieder kenny chen deming
spiel hat man wieder ein level wie dein
leben und warum also das ist louis und
dann lädt der noch ein advents block
hoch und das ist einfach weiß nicht
irgendwie ganz cool aber eben es noch
packe 16 ist ganz einfach von kiefern
ist cool 17 hat auch wieder was mit
instagram zu tun habe ich am anfang
schon erwähnt ins amt kommt aber
instagram kommentare durchlese finde ich
irgendwie richtig witzig weil das wohl
sonst
alfermann komme ich poste im bild und da
stehen sie kommentaren unter wie die
einfach überhaupt nichts mit dem bild zu
tun haben so erfolgt wie rauch oder
heiko ueding ich habe effekt für dich
und ich möchte einfach bei instagram ich
komme daran die sich auf das bild
beziehen also brauchte weihnachtsbaum
hey wo bist du oder war der sehr schönes
oder herr conti habt ihr auch schon
seine frauen gekauft doch nicht so herr
egger nicht merkwürdig oder helft mir
auch vor verfolgung am sonntag also ich
finde das so witzig was nicht für
scheiße darunter geschrieben wird es ist
18 ich liebe es einfach in photoshop
herumzubasteln das ist die sache
deswegen habe ich auch fast jede woche
irgendwie eine neue phase da irgendwas
neues design oder irgendwas neue weil
ich einfach immer wenn ich langeweile
habe ich den photoshop bastl einfach ein
bisschen rum kommt was man noch besser
machen kann
filter drauf packen und 19 ist so ein
bisschen asymmetrischer und zwar ich mag
es einfach leute zu ärgern also wenn man
jetzt nicht ihnen wieso einem aufs maul
hauen oder sagen würde da beide flügel
dagegen gesetzt sondern er seine schüler
einfach einen strich dann aufs blatt
malen oder sowas weiß nicht so kleine
sachen halt irgendwie version nicht da
kriegt man das dann halt auch immer
wieder zurück und dann rege ich mich
auch auf
aber egal irgendwie sowas mag ich auch
im einfachen leute bis merck hat 20 fifa
fifa ohne gegenseitige liebe ich liebe
fifa ich liebe fifa spielen ich liebe
die turniere
das ist megageil aber irgendwie hast
dich auch fifa fifa ist echt scheiße
wenn man irgendwie spielt und vielfalt
ist das einzige spiel das ich richtig
aufregen kann scheiß auf world of
warcraft oder league of legends spiel
das ja alles gar nicht oder was gibt es
noch so wo man sich über die counter
strike cod battlefield irgendwie sowas
kann ich spielen wie ich will
minecraft auch ich kann das spielen wie
ich will aber das einzige spiel wo ich
mich richtig auf rege ist fifa fifa ist
einfach ein auftrag spiel das mega
heftig aber ich ließ trotzdem freude das
war's mit der heutigen folge des
kontakts zu dem heutigen kontakt wie
gesagt wenn ihr etwas spezielles für die
nächste folge haben wollt dann klickt
einfach auf den obersten link in der
beschreibung und stimmte ab was ihr
haben wollt und pickel
weg machen hier ja okay jetzt kommt noch
dieses obligatorische wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lass doch einer
bewertung da weil die meisten das eh
nicht machen wenn man es nicht sagt also
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lass eine
bewertung dar wenn nicht auch aber dann
halt negativ also wie es wollt bewertet
das video wie ihr wollt schreibt mir
dass eine kommentare ob ihr auch so ein
paar sachen gleich mögt wie ich und
sonst sehen wir uns dann im nächsten
video wieder was ihr von mir angemeldet